as parents around the country and
especially around virginia storm school
board meetings to keep radicalism out of
the classroom and boys out of the girls
room
democrat gubernatorial candidate terry
mcauliffe is doubling down on his
promise to keep parents out of their
kids education most recently insisting
that the ideology of diversity and
inclusion
is as important to a student's education
as math or english class
i make the point that we've got to do a
better
job in our education system we've got to
go back k to six
early on we've got to start teaching
talking about these issues much earlier
than we've done it before and we don't
do a good job in our education system
talking about diversity inclusion
openness and so forth we don't we've got
our textbooks but you know there has to
be a big part of how
how do you fit in into the social work
of our nation in our fabric how is it
that we deal with one another is to me
is as important as you know your math
class your english class and so forth
and we don't
as the liberal ruling class turns up the
pressure on normal americans people are
starting to break rank a prominent yale
scholar is encouraging parents to
homeschool dave chappelle is refusing to
cower to the radicals down in florida
governor ron desantis is calling out the
regime by name i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from eddie gesh who
says you know i remember a time not that
long ago when we were energy independent
yes there was a time not that long ago
we were energy independent the economy
was great unemployment was at historic
lows we were defending america keeping a
lot of crap out of the classroom
enforcing our immigration laws
how long ago oh that was like what three
years ago or something but now it's much
that was in the bad days when everything
was working and now it's we're in the
good days where nothing is working
and prices are going through the roof
and the grocery shelves are empty and
every time you fill up your gas tank you
nearly go bankrupt well i've got
one way to help fix that last problem
you gotta check out get
upside i am thrilled to introduce an
incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about and needs to get
right now it is get upside
my listeners are making up to 25 cents
for every gallon of gas that they get
every time they fill up
how you do it it's very simple you
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
the promo code knowles get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
which means up to 50 cents cash back
you don't pay full price at the pump
anymore okay you get cash back using get
upside down load the app for free use
promo code no scanner wlas to get up to
50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first tank some people who drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred bucks per month in cash back
there's no catch the cash back gets
added right into your account you don't
need to go chase it down okay you can
cash out any time to your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon or
other brands just download the free get
upside app use promo code knowledge can
wles to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank that is code
can or wles
terry mcauliffe says that inclusion and
diversity and openness the ideology of
our of our regime that's just not taught
in schools not nearly as well as it
should be now listen i have not been in
school in a long time
i graduated in from college about nine
years ago graduated from high school
what 13 years ago
and
therefore i graduated from
middle school 17 years ago
and i graduated from elementary school
20 years ago
and
even then in all of those schools
including elementary school
they were already teaching the ideology
of diversity and inclusion and openness
a lot quite a lot okay we've been
teaching that in our country for a very
very very long time
to the detriment and the neglect of
english and math and history and all of
the actual subjects i actually agree
with terry mcauliffe in his most broad
philosophical point when he says
teaching students how to get along
together and how to be citizens with one
another that is a very important part of
education that's true that was the point
of civics but we've replaced civics we
no longer teach
about the american system of government
and we no longer teach about the
brilliance of the founding fathers and
the men who developed our country we no
longer inculcate in our students a love
of country and a desire to be a good
citizen we do the opposite we teach them
that the country's evil that the
founders were evil and that the best way
to be a citizen is to tear everything
down that is achieving the opposite goal
from the
idea of
proper civic education
and the whole time we're also neglecting
the actual academic
subjects
that's what we got to teach though and
if parents don't want to teach
diversity and equity and inclusion well
they can go to hell because
i terry mcauliffe
i the virginia
state bureaucracy i the
school boards in virginia we are going
to make the decisions
even if it means
that a little girl gets raped
in a high school bathroom you know that
story this is the story the daily wire
broke no one wanted to talk about it
daily wire broke the story
they've got transgender bathrooms in
loudoun county and a boy who wears a
dress
viciously rape i mean the most extreme
rape i'm not going to go into the
details it's as horrific as it gets
in a bathroom because a boy went into
the girls room a boy who's allowed to
pretend that he's a girl sometimes and
boys and girls are allowed to go into
whatever bathroom they want
a girl was victimized and then the
school covered it up because the school
is obviously guilty here of at least
extraordinarily extraordinary negligence
or extraordinary ideology
they are guilty of prioritizing their
ideological delusions over the safety of
their students well
first the school tried to cover it up
then the school tried to deny it now a
virginia court has ruled there is enough
evidence to find that this boy who
occasionally pretends to be a girl did
in fact engage in quote non-consensual
sex
now maybe me maybe i'm just
old-fashioned maybe i'm just a little
thick and stupid but when i was a kid
non-consensual sex was called rape but
now we don't call it rape because rape
is is a evokes real images it's an
evocative
word
non-consensual sex that's just another
kind of pc jargon to
to
paper over
the harsh reality of this situation
the radical leftists
in virginia schools engaged in a
delusional policy based on the false
premise that boys can be girls and girls
can be boys
and
as a result of this a girl was raped and
they don't want to take responsibility
well that's what happened
and terry mcauliffe has to own that the
parents are saying
we don't want this in our schools
the leftists are saying we do want this
in our schools
it is not an exaggeration to say that
terry mcauliffe has to own this
michael how can you say terry terry
mcauliffe doesn't run the school he's
not the superintendent he's not the
principal he didn't even push this
policy in the
school come on michael look it might
have happened even if they didn't have
the transgender bathrooms yeah maybe it
would have been a lot harder first of
all
would have been a lot less
likely to have happened
and the buck stops with the governor
this guy was the governor terry
mcauliffe he wants to be the governor
again and he's pushing for these
policies
so he owns it
and this is not just at the local level
it's not even just at the level of
virginia and the commonwealth and state
level it goes up to the national level
and i but i think people are misreading
the real motivations here so
the white house just released the
national strategy on gender equity and
equality okay this kamala harris just
tweeted it out
you've got container ships off the coast
that can't get any goods and services to
get any good i suppose they don't have a
lot of services on the container ships
you go into a grocery store the shelves
are empty you go to the gas tank the
prices are through the roof
you try to go into a restaurant but
you've got to show your your vax
passport people are losing their jobs if
they won't take the fouchiauchi
countries in turmoil that's why we need
a national strategy on gender equity and
equality right
a lot of people think
one this is a big distraction
a lot of people think two this is
marxism you know this is some radicalism
and and it's undermining our great
liberal democracy
i think there's something
even more basic at play here just listen
to the first paragraph of the national
strategy on gender equity inequality
president biden and vice president
harris believe that advancing gender
equity and equality is fundamental to
every individual's economic security
safety health and ability to exercise
their most basic rights it is also
essential to economic growth and
development
democracy and political stability and
security of nations across the globe
economic growth hold on gender equity is
important to economic growth
you go down a few periods some more
platitudes in here and then
then you see this strategy identifies
ten interconnected priorities guess what
number one is
economic security
it seems to me that all this crazy
gender focus and the the push of
transgenderism and feminism and making
sure that women work as much as they
possibly can in the widget factory and
never stay home and raise their kids and
never have a family and never run the
household and they just work work work
for the man i think
that a lot of this
comes not even necessarily from marxism
or from radical social theory i think a
lot of it just comes from neoliberalism
i think a lot of it comes from the
ruling elite that just wants to make as
much money as they possibly can and when
half the country is staying home raising
kids they're not going to make as much
money and gdp is not going to be as high
so they've got to force women out of the
home and they've got to force women to
go work for some guy doing spreadsheets
for their entire life so that they can
make enough money so that they can pay
some other woman to raise their kids if
they choose to have kids at all which is
increasingly
less and less common
and i think that's really what it's
about
you'll notice after the economic issue
you've got
improving economic security then they
talk about gender-based violence
and then they say increasing access to
healthcare what do they mean by health
care it says it right here in the second
bullet point defend the constitutional
right to safe and legal abortion in the
united states established in roe versus
weight and promote access to sexual and
reproductive health and rights both at
home and abroad of course abortion is
not reproductive health or it's the
opposite of reproduction right it's
killing a baby why why do they push
abortion
in part it's these radical social
theories but in part it's that
women won't can't be expected to just go
back and work all the time and and and
continue to
seem indiscernible for men if they can't
kill their babies because babies have
the ability to conceive and bear
children is a difference between men and
women so you've got to push
contraception you've got to push
abortion you've got to push women out of
the home this was a big debate between
betty friedan the american feminist and
simone de beauvoir the french feminist
betty friedan said give women the choice
to work or stay home simone de beauvoir
said no you can't if if you give women
the choice too many of them will stay
home and that's not conducive to
liberation and i think our our
neo-liberal ruling class i think they
see the exact same
thing
follow as always in politics follow the
money
we got to protect our civilization
we've got to protect
our
homes
when you want to protect your home i'd
recommend you check out ring you know
that i go on the road a fair bit and
sometimes when i go on the road i go
solo and i'd like to know that my wife
and sweet little baby can know who is
outside the door before they open that
door and sometimes i take the family
with me and then i still get incredible
peace of mind from ring
with ring you can keep an eye on your
home not just that you all know about
the video doorbell where you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door
wherever you are whether you're in the
home at the office on the beach on the
other side of the world
but you can keep an eye on every inch of
your home inside and out you control it
all from the very simple app
it's extraordinarily easy to install
even i can do it
and with the full ring alarm system you
can subscribe get even even more
features and it's extremely inexpensive
it's just a terrific product all the way
around protect your home anytime from
anywhere with ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles canon wles for a special offer
on a ring alarm security kit today build
a system that is right for your home
have it up and running in minutes that
is ring dot com slash knowles k w l e s
ring dot com slash knowles the white
house has a national strategy on gender
equity and equality nothing says
girl power
quite like that news this week that a
man has now been promoted to the first
female four-star admiral in the united
states you know this dr richard levine
who is the assistant secretary of health
and he goes by rachel now and he the
assistant secretary of health is a man
who believes that he is a woman
though he of course is not
he was just given
this promotion to four-star admiral he's
not in the military he's a four-star
admiral in the
commissioned core of the public health
service and they say that he's a female
admiral but of course
he is not because he's a dude nothing
says girl power like a man taking a
woman's job it's also just not true so
we covered the levine story a couple of
days ago
but
one aspect of it that we're missing is
that
while the the media are reporting on
this guy as though he's the first female
four-star admiral he's not that that
honor would go to admiral michelle j
howard
she is uh the first woman to become a
four-star admiral she retired from the
navy four years ago
so it's not even levine is not even
close
he can claim to be the first
guy who
says that he's a woman to become an
admiral
i think that he would get he might he
might
claim to be the first female admiral in
the
public health corps but he again because
he's not a woman that claimed i could
claim to be a giant octopus and it does
you know it wouldn't be true
but even the claim that the media are
making here they are erasing an actual
woman who actually attained this title
in
deference to the new transgender
ideology speaking of unfairly taking
credit for the accomplishments of other
people
and speaking of terry mcauliffe
there's something
even more
delicious about watching mcauliffe
squirm in virginia mcauliffe tried to
defend this indefensible position that
parents should have no right in their
kids education mcauliffe really
beginning to fall in the polls in a blue
state
because of this issue which is that
terry mcauliffe is also really
undermining the democrats favorite
slogan of the right-wing
insurrectionists you know what the left
has been telling us for the past year at
least
is that if you question the results of
an election you are undermining our
democracy and you're an insurrectionist
and you're a domestic terrorist
and then
what did terry mcauliffe do this week
he denied
the results of an election
so let me now bring out
she would be the governor of georgia
today had the governor of georgia not
disenfranchised 1.4 million georgia
voters before the election
that's what happened to stacey abrams
they took the votes away that's what
happened
it was it was illegitimate it was unfair
oh my goodness someone call adam schiff
someone call liz cheney that great
defender of our this man
this man terry mcauliffe he's inciting
an insurrection he's eroding faith in
our institutions he's undermining our
democracy he's doing that a hell of a
lot more clearly than the horn guy at
the capitol or the smiley guy who took
pelosi's lectern by golly this man's a
former governor
this man's running for governor again
and he
oh pl liz cheney i know that you're so
earnest and sincere in your in your
defense of our institutions well let's
have an investigation of terry mcauliffe
right except we won't except we won't by
the way terry mcauliffe earlier
i think just last month terry mcauliffe
was asked what he thought about the 2000
presidential election bush versus gore
and he denied the results of that
election too
and of course the left has done this for
a long time they did it in 2000 they did
it in 2016 they still haven't admitted
that hillary lost and they they
pretended that trump didn't win and
they're still doing it with stacey
abrams
so it's just bunk it's just bunk and
people like liz cheney and adam
kinzinger he's he's like the store brand
liz cheney
and
all of the rest of the democrats i know
that cheney and kinzinger have an r next
to their name but you know all the
democrats
they're just full of it and there's just
no reason to take any of that seriously
and the whole purpose of the
insurrection talk and all of that is to
split the right it's to split the
squishes the people who go a little
lilly-livered and weak in the knee away
from the rock-ribbed people but i'm i'm
pleading with you lily-livered people
and those who go weak in the knee don't
fall for it it's a trap it's a lie they
don't believe any of it and they they
undermine our democracy in our elections
every chance that they get
if mcauliffe goes down
if terry mcauliffe fails in virginia and
the republican glenn younkin wins
it will
it will not be because of undermining
faith in our institutions
and it won't be because of taxes and it
won't be because of immigration it will
be because
of this school issue this is a really
important issue this is an issue that i
think can bring together a lot of people
who are conservative who are libertarian
who are normal who are
who are of any any stripe who are even
left-wing but still kind of reasonable
they're going to say no of course you
know our kids are in these schools for
eight hours a day or more
our kids are going to be there for 13
years or more so if we want to have any
say in how our children are raised we
need to have some say in the schools
and this has a medical aspect too right
now the schools are trying to force the
fouchy algae on a bunch of healthy kids
who face
statistically very very very very low
risk of hospitalization or death from
coronavirus an infinitesimally small
risk
and at least according to one study from
uc davis
they might face some risk from
the vaccine and we don't we really don't
know there are no long-term data on the
vaccine just by definition the vaccine
is very new
and so
there's a real question that parents are
facing why would i inject my kid with
this experimental drug
when the drug is supposed to protect
against a virus that poses
almost no very very low risk to him
well that argument is getting buttressed
by a very serious well-credentialed
epidemiologist that would be
professor harvey rich at yale so he's
one of the top schools in the country
harvey rich says if you as a parent are
facing the choice between
injecting your kid with the fouchy algae
even if he is otherwise healthy and
pulling your kid out of school
you should probably do the latter
if the child has chronic conditions that
make their risk appreciable then there's
a reason that they would should be
considered for vaccination
other than that
if it were my child i would homeschool
them honestly i would organize with
other parents
to take them out of the school and
create homeschooling environments
there's no choice your child's life is
on the line it's not a high risk
vaccination is not a high risk that's
going to kill every child by doing so
however it's enough of a risk that on
the average the benefit is higher for
homeschooling than it is for for
vaccination and being in school and
that's just the bottom line you know we
were seeing employees in companies
facing mandates quit or being fired and
now the public perceives that and
and companies are having a hard time
replacing those employees in the climate
of a bad employment circumstances and
and missing workers it's getting even
harder so those policies are being
rethought when the people rebel because
of their own interests then it has to be
reckoned
it does have to be reckoned and
i think the great relief here for a lot
of people is not even that
that this guy is pointing out the the
questions about the vaccine or you know
permitting the
at least giving parents the
permission the intellectual permission
to go put their kids in homeschool
it's that finally we're seeing a
scientist who sees the big picture
this was this was one thing that really
bugged me about trump i know his back
was against a wall he was facing this
unprecedented crisis and everyone and
every
power in the entire country was coming
after him and demanding that he lock
down and listen to fouchy but the big
mistake here
for those early coronavirus press
conferences
was that
the only people who talked were trump
and the doctors
right fouchy and dr scarf and the other
one that surgeon general jerk who spends
all his time now just attacking
conservatives
was this jerome powell is that his name
jerome not jerome powell
jerome adams yes that's right jerome
adams so
why is that the problem well the left
said all we should be listening to
is dr fauci and dr scarf and jerome
adams
we
all we should be listening to are the
doctors but that's not true because it
it's a country we're talking about the
politics politics refers to public
things there's more to the public than
just germs
trump also probably should have had a
military advisor get up there and speak
and had an economic advisor get up there
and speak and had a constitutional
advisor get up there and speak and had
people speak from different segments of
society because what what the president
is supposed to do in particular but what
our public representatives are supposed
to do is bring together all these
different segments all these different
interests in society so that we can have
a coherent balanced public policy but
that's not how the regime wants to
govern itself okay that is not how the
technocratic progressive regime wants to
be wants to be just run by a bunch of
eggheads that kick out every other
interest in society and there's at least
one
republican governor in this country who
sees the problem for exactly what it is
by the way if you haven't already
heard the news the daily wire has signed
allison williams to lead a very special
sports series exclusively for our
members allison was a seasoned sports
reporter for espn she announced her
resignation last week because disney
which is espn's parent company is
forcing their employees to receive the
fauci ouchy or get fired well here at
the daily wire leftist elites do not get
to dictate our content you do so if you
want sports content without the woke
then
become a member at dailywire.com
subscribe and use code do not comply at
checkout
you will get 25 off that is
dailywire.com
subscribe code do not comply for 25 off
and join the fight also
you can subscribe and start listening
out to morning wire on apple spotify
wherever you listen to your podcast
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear we'll be right back with a
lot more
when the yale epidemiologist harvey rich
comes out and says parents should pull
their kids out of school if the schools
are going to demand they take this
experimental fouchy algae
i think
this is a great surprise this is
wonderful and the most surprising thing
here might be
that someone from yale is doing that
yale is a very far-left place right now
so it's great to see that's very
shocking that's kind of the cherry on
top of the sunday well there's another
guy who came from yale who is standing
up to this regime
that would be the governor of florida
ron desantis who is calling out our
ruling class by name
we're not going to let the federal
government come in and impose
bad policies or mandates on floridians
we're going to make sure we're
protecting parents and students in the
state of florida we're not going to let
the department of justice be weaponized
to infringe first amendment rights of
parents we're going to fight to preserve
the rights of parents and as we continue
to see uh the use of fear and
intimidation to suppress opposition to
the regime
we're going to find new ways to be able
to empower parents rights to decide what
is best for your for their children
that one word
that one word gives you the clue
that ron desantis sees what's going on
here
regime
what do we mean by regime regime is a
little different than the democrats
regime is a little different than the
leftists
regime is the entire ruling power
structure
which includes some republicans
and it includes some squishes
and it includes some people who probably
wouldn't even call themselves political
like dr fauci dr fatty says i'm not
political
i'm just in public health now this is a
complete nonsense politics refers to
public affairs
but he thinks no no but i'm just i'm in
public health i'm just a scientist i
just follow the science and you all have
to do whatever i say but that doesn't
make me a politician
i'm not the ruler i'm merely the vessel
of the science right and there is the
public health establishment then there
are all those other agencies
you know all of those other agencies
like osha the occupational safety and
health administration osha is the
organization tasked with forcing all of
you to take the experimental fauciachi
right it's not it's not even biden it's
not like it's the courts it's not like
it's some legislator who did this it's
biden tasking some random bureaucrat
part of the regime and desantis is
calling that out by name and regimes by
the way
have ruling ideologies what is the
ruling ideology now you keep hearing
everyone talking about it not just
democrats but even some republicans
diversity equity and inclusion
we need all hell diversity equity and
inclusion what is that's a weird mantra
it's a weird kind of religious mantra
that is one of the
things that animates the regime and
desantis is calling out the whole damn
thing not
just the democrats not just the left but
the whole
thing and was this just an accident was
this just some speech writer threw it in
and he didn't know what he was saying no
i don't think so because i was just with
ron desantis two nights ago three nights
ago in in los angeles i went out i may
have mentioned it on the show last week
i was emceing
a dinner the annual claremont institute
gala in los angeles they actually had to
relocate from los angeles to the more
conservative orange county because of
all of all of the stupid mandates in l.a
ron desantis was the
award recipient he won the statesmanship
award that night and so i
had a long opportunity to speak with him
at the table over dinner and then i got
to hear his
speech
and he used a lot of the same language
in the speech
and he was
he called out the regime by name in the
speech
and he
described the ways in which the
republican party and the conservatives
have been kind of wrong and they're
shallow in their approach over the last
20 years he he said a lot of the same
things that we say on this show
and it's kind of in the current right
now this is a guy i think who knows
what time it is and i think it's very a
lot of other conservatives are catching
on to this too desantis is getting a lot
of attention because he's a governor so
he's got an executive role in florida he
clearly wants to be president so he's
putting himself into
national politics
but he also get there are other people
who are governors who want to be
president who don't get it christy gnome
in south dakota has made misstep after
misstep falling back on the same
ridiculous talking points the same
corporatist
uh you know uh sucking up
to the the various woke interests that
when push comes to shove she's not going
to stand up for
the difference between men and women
when push comes to shove she's not going
to stand up for the rights of people to
maintain their way of life over the
rights of employers to force everyone to
take the voucher she's at the crucial
moment she's kind of broken desantis is
not
okay this is a very good sign for
desantis in florida and for for whatever
ambitions he has after florida but it's
not just governors who can do something
here
you've seen some some people stand up in
the senate for instance and kind of know
what time it is there but ordinary
people too
there's a great story i just saw on cbs
evening news
i don't remember the last time i uttered
that sentence but there was a really
great story on cbs evening news about
some dads in louisiana there was a
school in louisiana
where 23 students
had been arrested for fighting over the
course of three days and the schools
were useless and the politicians were
useless and the administrators were
useless at stopping this and so what
happened that a bunch of dads stepped in
and started
keeping the peace in the school and what
do you know everything got better
nobody here has a degree in school
counseling
no majors in criminal justice no no your
qualifications are fair
we decided the best people who can take
care of our kids or who for us i
immediately felt a form of safety we
stopped fighting people started going to
class how could that be you ever heard
of a look a look dads have the power to
do that yes
not many people know it but yes
they just make funny jokes like oh hey
your student's untied but it's really
not untied and they hate it they're so
embarrassed by it
and it's that perfect mix of tough love
and gentle ribbing that dads do so well
that has helped transform this school
the school has really just been like
happy and you can feel it because not
everybody has a father a father figure
at home or a male period in their life
so just to be here makes a big
difference
so there is so much wisdom in this
segment and there's so much wisdom in
what these dads are doing
i think there are two levels here
there's the first level which i think we
all know which is that fatherlessness
causes the decay of society you've
noticed this especially in the black
community because
rates of out of wedlock birth are some
something over 70 percent now
and
and fatherlessness has been blamed for a
lot of the sort of social pathologies
specifically among black americans and
it's true wherever it rears its ugly
head this problem of fatherlessness so
we all know yeah you got to protect the
family you start with good families you
keep the father at home you're going to
have a much better society but there's
there's a deeper level of wisdom even
here too
what are the fathers doing the fathers
are
showing in the home and at the schools
they're showing up
and providing leadership
and a good example
and some levity you know some some of
these little jokes the dad jokes that
everyone talks about
and restraint
and authority
and limits
and the look what did that girl say she
said he said how do these dads do it
it's not like they have any degrees it's
not like they've got any particular
governmental authority she goes you ever
hear of a look
you ever you know and dad gives you what
is that look that look is
a warning
that look is a threat
but that that warning and that threat is
coming from someone who does love you
and who does want what's best for you
and who is entrusted with your care so
he doesn't want to go kill you he
doesn't want to destroy your life but he
wants to
exercise his authority
and to constrain your desires and basis
appetites
to make sure that you flourish
this is what politics does
okay this
the family is the fundamental building
block of society it's the smallest
political unit then you have the local
community then you have the state then
you have the national government but the
principles apply the whole time
and a good political community is not
libertine and licentious and doesn't say
just do whatever you want a good dad
doesn't say go do whatever you want oh
yeah go do a bunch of drugs stay out all
night drinking teenager yeah go sleep
with whoever you want yeah don't do your
homework if you don't want to do it i'm
a good dad because i'm respecting your
freedom no that's not freedom it's going
to destroy somebody
it doesn't work at the family level
doesn't work at
the local or the state or the national
level either
you need
wise leadership judgment prudence
restraint
the left
doesn't like that
the left blew out all of the restraints
and now they're reimposing them along
their own lines and the conservatives
are so stuck in a bunch of libertarian
clap trap that they won't do it either
when the left says let's legalize all
the drugs what does the right say okay
well actually i read some stupid
libertarian essay a few years ago so
yeah let's legalize all the drugs the
left says let's get rid of all sexual
moraes the right says well you know i'm
my i love liberty and so if liberty
means letting anyone sleep with whoever
they want however often they want
wherever with as many people that's
totally that's cool whatever let's do
that liberty no guys
take a lesson from those dads those dads
get it listen to those kids those kids
get it and look at the difference in
what's going on in those schools
speaking of
cool black guys standing up against
liberal decadence this is a very narrow
category of topic but it but it works
dave chappelle
dave chappelle's in big trouble
dave chappelle had a netflix special
dave chappelle mocked the idea that a
boy can become a girl
and now he's in big trouble and there
are protests in netflix and the netflix
ceo initially stood by chappelle but now
he's kind of caving and he's going weak
and
and dave is under the gun so dave
released
a response to the transgender activists
who are demanding his head on a platter
and dave's response was in my view pitch
perfect
to the transgender community i'm more
than willing
to give you an audience
but she will not summon me
i am not bending to anybody's demands
and if you want to meet with me i'd be
more than willing to
but i have some conditions
first of all
you cannot come
if you have not watched my special from
beginning to end
you must come to a place of my choosing
and a time
of my choosing
and thirdly
you must admit that hannah gatsby is not
funny
[Music]
absolutely
right and so the the punch line is what
everyone's focusing on here hannah
gadsby was trending yesterday she is
this woman who did a netflix comedy
special but the whole
hook of the special was that she wasn't
actually doing comedy they said she has
redefined comedy because what she said
wasn't funny and it was all just kind of
sad and it wasn't even really supposed
to be funny it was just sad
and so she had redefined comedy and this
was the new comedy and by the way there
was a word for the new comedy it's
called tragedy
but the the idiot critics
did not know because they didn't know
that word at the time so audiences hated
hannah gadsby's special but the critics
loved it if you look on rotten tomatoes
it's got 90 plus i think it's like 96
critic score and
a very very low audience score then if
you look at chappelle's special it's got
a very low critic score but a very high
audience score that's how you can tell
that dave chappelle is doing a good job
so everyone's focusing on the punch line
you got to do this you got to do this
and you got to admit hannah gadsby's not
funny but the setup of the joke is
what's more important politically this
is i'm not just playing the chappelle
club because he's a funny guy and we can
all get a laugh i'm doing it because
he's got a political lesson here and the
political lesson
is
is throughout and it's really more
focused on the first two things he says
he frames
the debate
chappelle obviously understands politics
so right now he's being protested
there's a lot of money on the line i
mean he gets paid very well for these
specials and if netflix isn't going to
work for him anymore and if the radical
leftists and the lgbt lmnop activists
are are successful then he's not going
to work again and he's going to lose
millions and millions of dollars and
maybe chappelle doesn't care he's a
wealthy guy but i think he wants to keep
doing comedy and so what he does is he
goes listen
i'm i'm willing to talk to you people
sure you you're demanding that you talk
to me he had another funny line in his
response where he said the the
transgender people are saying they don't
feel safe he goes i'm the only person
who's not allowed into the netflix
office right now
i'm the only one who's being threatened
here you guys aren't being threatened at
all
but he frames the debate he says i'm
willing to talk to you on my terms
you do it
first of all you have to watch my
special i'm putting a constraint on you
i'm making a demand of you then you got
to come where i want you to come then
you got to do it at a time when i want
you to do it and then you need to admit
this is this is the little cherry on top
and he says you need to admit that
hannah gatsby is not funny what he's
saying is you need to admit that i have
a point
and you need to admit that the people
support me
and you need to admit that the people
support me because i'm right
okay
there's a lot a lot here this is the
reason it's funny i mean you know it's
the old old line from any comedy club
people say it's funny because it's true
that's what's going on here it's dave
chappelle's
special and his response are funny
because they're true and there's an
important lesson when you look at the
people who are right now really standing
up in executive positions in politics
whether it's at a comedy special or in
florida or in the united at the national
level
desantis sets the debate donald trump
sets the debate he's always framing the
debate from his point of view whoever
frames the issue
wins
the debate
i don't think
that the uproar about ron desantis or
about the curricula in schools and
critical race theory and gender theory
and big tech and all of these
related issues they all what we are
being told
by
the geniuses out there is that this is
all about censorship
free speech or censorship
that's what we're being told by the
geniuses on the right or on the non-left
you know the disaffected leftists
a great example of this would be glenn
greenwald
he says
glenn greenwald is this i guess formerly
leftist journalist now he's kind of
independent nobody owns him he has a
relationship with wikileaks
says a lot of interesting and correct
things and says some other things that
are a little kooky he says quote
i regard it as nothing short of tragic
that free speech which began as a core
enlightenment value and then was built
into a real ideology by the u.s left
in bold in the 20th century is now
demonized as a right-wing view and
begging google to police our speech is
left-wing orthodoxy
i regard that as nothing short of tragic
to glenn but i suspect it's for
different reasons
it is true that right now free speech
is the is a right-wing cause and
censorship is the left-wing cause it is
true that free speech began as an
enlightenment value core enlightenment
value
is that a good thing or a bad thing i
don't know i'm not a huge enlightenment
guy
i know that a lot of right wingers now
make themselves out to be big
enlightenment guys but i don't know i
kind of like the older stuff you know
maybe i'm a little old-fashioned but
i don't think that the enlightenment i
don't think that the
18th century
and afterward i don't think that was the
peak of
european civilization i think it was
more like the
16th century or even a little earlier
maybe the 15th century
maybe even a little earlier than that
when you think of all the great works in
the west you think of the high middle
ages
you think of the great developments in
philosophy the great developments in art
and architecture and the beautiful
cathedrals and all the wonderful
paintings it was all before the
enlightenment
as far as i can tell the enlightenment
was kind of the beginning of the end and
everything started to fall apart you had
all these insane ideologies that came
out of it well you had liberalism was
the chief export of the enlightenment
but then you know communism fascism kind
of fall out after during the age of
ideology
everything starts to fall apart
is that so it's a core enlightenment
value it was built into a real ideology
by the u.s left i think that's true i
think whatever free speech meant during
the enlightenment
it's not what it means now and i talk
about this in my book but if you read
what john locke the father of liberalism
writes about free speech it is very
different it's much more right-wing it's
much more authoritarian than the way we
talk about it now
john locke didn't think atheists had any
right to speak okay
john milton didn't think that atheists
or catholics even for that matter had
any right to speak really so
yes it became a real ideology built by
the us left and now it's it's described
as a right-wing view but it's not a
right-wing view what we should recognize
i'm going to be speaking in
miami tonight at the university of miami
i'm going to be speaking about dave
chappelle i'm going to be speaking about
the black panther party i'm going to be
speaking about the
the way in which we talk about free
speech today
i'm going to cover some ground we
haven't covered before it might be a
little bit of a barn burner it should be
fun if you're out in miami come on come
on out uh
i think this is a big mistake
i know that we have this boogeyman of
authoritarian authoritarianism no
we're the we're the real liberals that's
what conservatives say now we're the i'm
a conservative because i'm a real
liberal i'm not a real liberal i don't
know i'm not i'm a conservative because
i'm a conservative
call me simple but
i think that
those dads in louisiana make a really
good point
yes we want people to be free the point
of education is to make us free
right it's to make us
it's to learn the liberal arts it's to
have a liberal education to make sense
of our freedom and that involves
guidance and guardrails and limits and
frankly even a little bit of coercion
and a little bit of a threat of
transgressing you don't want to
transcribe you don't want to get into
fights you don't want to do bad things
because dad's going to give you that
look
okay and because there is such a thing
as the law and there are social mores
and there at least once was a coherent
society that had standards and taboos
and that's how you become free you don't
become free by doing whatever you want
and sleeping with whoever you want and
doing whatever drugs you want
club and getting into whatever fights
you want okay speaking of truth and
falsehood
which i think is really what's at stake
here we're talking the way we talk about
free speech is just you can say whatever
you want or you can't say whatever you
want how about what if you can just say
true things
what if we defend true things and we
suppress false things what if we do that
in the
traditional kind of
way that we've understood speech and
politics
well speaking of truth in falsehood we
have one of the greatest
one of the greatest corrections in the
history of the media
this by way of the washington post
headline
biden's critics hurl increasingly vulgar
taunts
this is really
this is really
something else given what we endured
from the left during the trump years
during the trump years women wore a hat
that was named after
a vulgar term for uh for female
genitalia right and that that was like
a common expression they put it on their
heads and all the f this and f trump and
this and that and all the vulgar and
they would they would make tv
commercials with little kids screaming
all these sorts of vulgar words but now
they're clutching their pearls they're
holier than that okay well biden's
critics hurl increasingly vulgar taunts
where's the correction because okay you
don't need to read the whole article
where's the oh here's the correction oh
this is good
correction a previous version of this
article incorrectly said a crowd broke
into a let's go brandon chant during a
donald trump jr speech in georgia the
crowd broke into an f joe biden chant at
that speech in september the error which
was inserted by an editor has been
corrected
we've reached the top we've reached the
peak when you because the phrase let's
go brandon is just a euphemism for f joe
biden and it's a euphemism that came
about because some sports reporter heard
a crowd chanting f joe biden and she was
talking to a guy named brandon and she
pretended that they were chanting let's
go brandon and then the wright adopted
that as a joke but what we're really
saying is f joe biden hahaha and that is
a revolt
okay that is a revolt against
not just the democrats not just the libs
not just the left it's a revolt against
the ruling class in this country okay
and it's catching on
well beyond the narrow rock ribbed
republicans
well beyond the gop activists it's cat
it's catching on in a lot of places and
not even the washington post can cover
that up
the media are losing a bit of their
monopoly here the ruling class is losing
a bit of their monopoly on the flow of
information and
the control of public opinion we got to
keep pushing harder and harder and
harder a lot of people are waking up
we've got a lot of good allies here but
now is the time
for courage i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles shall see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show dave
chappelle tells the counselors to get
lost the media unified to take down
facebook for platforming conservatives
and the educational experts admit they
are coming for your kids that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen